yeah when I was a kid once my opponent
castled one side I chased it back to the
center so his King was back on a one and
he decided to Castle Queen side which is
not really legal I was playing a blitz
tournament once and i was playing this
season i am and i was completely winning
and then he snuck a queen back on the
board without it already been traded off
a long time ago the thing is that i just
actually didn't notice and the game
continued i called the arbiters and they
ruled it in his favor because he was i
guess more respected than i was at the
time I've not sure what the result was
if I had lost that would be pretty
unfortunate there was actually a tornado
warning so we had to stop the game for
maybe like 20 30 minutes it was my my
move when we stopped the clock and by
the time we came back to the board I
found the best plan and I played it and
helping win the game I was at a chess
tournament and then I think someone
blended a piece or something and then he
saw really loudly I got off the board
during the game and when I came back I
started the wrong table and I kept
thinking it took me about five minutes
to realize it was not in my position why
was it really sure what that meant so I
asked my parents and then they weren't
happy about it I was playing at someone
who all declined to name and he just
jumped up from the board ran to the side
of the room and loudly vomited into the
trash can and then came back and kept
playing